my college found out about my
embarrassing secret this is what
happened next
that's so funny welcome to the channel
where i do either extremely long videos
or very short videos and nothing in
between except for this one apparently
this is an exception so basically i
graduated right struggling how to figure
out how to like uh do this video in like
an authentic way it's absolutely true my
class did find about the channel um
which was very strange awkward
it was awkward it was strange but before
i start adam and eve let me tell you
about how babies are made so i don't
need to get into that adam and eve is
very cool there's 24 7 customer service
90 day no hassle returns discreet
shipping i would who i don't know why
that's important but it's good to know
that that exists adam and eve great
products great company they saved my
marriage that's a joke um and yeah but
go go check them out you get a disc i'm
giving you a discount code go to
adamandeve.com use code thing for 50 off
one item plus free shipping in the us
and canada some exclusions apply i
figured they asked me to be a sponsor
because all of my subscribers are super
cool and have sex all the time so back
to the video what am i talking about two
years ago
2020 everyone's inside for some apparent
reason who knows we'll get to the bottom
of that sometime and i start doing
videos about um books basically i kind
of had an unconventional path through
college and i think it's totally okay i
think you should go to college at any
age i'm 24
i turned 25 soon i was going to uh
community college and not really knowing
what i was doing with my life i wanted
to do youtube i wanted to do like film i
wanted to write you know a lot of stuff
that a lot of people want to do i felt
it was just very out of reach i was kind
of giving up hope and kind of living an
aimless life and then i met met nadia
being with her brought a lot of
new motivation in life you know and she
you know very very much
taught me how to you know
value myself
a little more and not be so uh cynical
about my
future prospects in life and then i
transferred to my dream school uh ucla
you know that was the school i applied
to back when i was you know 17. i
finally got into it unconventional way
what was the point starting ucla was
around the same time i started the
youtube channel so maybe that's why i'm
doing this video because it's almost
like graduating from college it's like
now now what you know and i never
expected that i would be doing youtube
still honestly i'm gonna keep it simple
about what worked for me on youtube it
works it's different for everybody what
worked for me was forcing myself to make
videos at first it was once a week then
it was twice a week and then it was
three times a week which was got really
hard especially with school with uh work
why why did you switch from the book
stuff to doing the like short memes and
and all that and it really was because
those are just a lot more fun to make
i really don't like sitting in front of
the camera and talking a lot um i don't
like editing it and i'm always going to
talk about books on the channel of
course always you know there's always a
place for that here because i just think
it's fun and kind of funny too you know
just that you have the really short
skits and then like talking about
weathering guides or whatever but it
came down to like uh
the pressure of needing to get videos
out and i'm like how do i do that
sometimes it's like hey just this is a
10 second video you're like i have only
this much time and i need to come up
with an idea that'll i could do in this
amount of time and still get my other
work done and you know so it's it's kind
of like just like a pressure cooker that
works and i feel like stress is
unfortunately a big motivator for me
it's kind of cool to be out of that a
little bit and have a little less stress
in life so things i learned being
exclusively a booktuber reviewing and
talking about books is extremely time
consuming uh you have to be like a super
human level of reader i feel like to be
able to motivate yourself to read all
the books you you need to to make
content and it's like you have to read
in order to have the content or whatever
and that's kind of how it started out
with me i was like kind of keeping up
with the reading at first and then i'm
like okay what can i start doing because
i haven't finished these books one of my
biggest goals for the channel was to do
like video essays so when i did the long
wheel of time video that was like a huge
accomplishment for me that was like a
major major deal and i'm extremely proud
of that video it just kind of happens i
think with a lot of youtubers or just
people who make stuff in general you you
just kind of fall into what you can and
try to find a place for yourself and
i had no plan and i still don't um and i
i think that's kind of honestly i think
that's a good place to be
i don't know what i'm saying but so
let's talk a bit about the channel
getting
big you know so the more i've done
youtube the more i realized like yeah
this just is it's just it's an amazing
job but it's not for
there's a lot of people who just
wouldn't like it because it's it's not
like i don't know it's like being a
carnival act you know you gotta i love
making these videos and i want to keep
doing it and i'm really grateful for
those who watch it and support me on
patreon it's surreal i mean it's really
weird you know because i always pictured
you know what it would be like doing
something like this and like dreamt like
oh that'd be so cool to be making
youtube videos and everything and it's
pretty it's pretty awesome but you know
there's a lot of insecurity with it
because it's all uh you know it's a lot
of pressure uh to be constantly
outperforming yourself you know it's
just it's just the way it is but i mean
a lot of jobs are like that a lot of
creative
uh pursuits i like that so school
was
long and a lot of work look so i'm an
english major and um you kind of have to
make the most of it uh it's kind of up
to you like you you just have to do your
work like doing the work getting the
work done like that's the main part but
everything else like it's it matters you
know who you meet you know what kind of
stuff you do organizations whatever most
of when i was at ucla was on zoom hence
all of the zoom videos i did people
thought i was a teacher
i'm not a teacher i'm not i'm not that
smart guys but right now the degree
hasn't really been that much help but
the experience was good
one of the classes i really wanted to do
was like a creative writing like a
creative writing workshop you know it's
like 12 or 13 people
great workshop i love doing writing
workshops i love writing with other
people some amazing writers in that
workshop too so someone all right so
someone found the channel this is very
weird to talk i don't know someone found
the channel they asked me about it very
politely and uh was like is this you
like yeah yeah yeah blushing as i as
they say that i told my teacher
about it
during office hours and uh he ended up
telling the class which is fine i don't
really care but it was very kind of
funny and and weird and i'm not ashamed
of it i'm very happy to like have people
see it but it's also a weird you know i
don't really know how to talk about it i
guess
what i'm trying to say i'm done with
college
and i feel very
free and happy to be done and i'm i'm
thankful to everyone who has been
supporting the channel for helping me
get through college i have some big
videos planned that are going to be a
lot of work but i'm excited for it you
know it's work that i like to do i want
to write
so that's what i'll be doing so what was
the point of this video i guess to share
my experience oh another thing there's
not a lot of mean comments or whatever
and i just i really like
that what i what i do on the channel is
just kind of have fun and not take
things too seriously it makes me very
happy it feels like this is what i was
meant to do in a lot of ways it feels
like this was something that it feels
like i'm finally i've had a lot of jobs
where i felt like horrible like i'm just
i can't do it and i don't have feel like
i'm finally doing something i'm good at
you know that's a very nice feeling to
have
i don't really have anything else to say
about that college for me was it was
important for me to do because i think i
needed the discipline i don't think i
would have pursued youtube if i weren't
in college because you're going off
without any guide rails you know you're
you're just going off into the void i
wanted some kind of security like hey i
can get an internship i need to get you
know a job after college whatever it's
surprising what we need in order to like
pursue our goals you know it's a weird
journey sometimes we take to find where
we fit it took me a while to like get to
this place where i feel really happy i
feel immensely lucky you know and i
wouldn't have done it without nadia
without a lot of people but especially
nadia who encouraged me
through college to do the youtube
channel channels
i feel like i've burnt out a bit i'm
ready for the next stage and i'm very
happy to be where i am very grateful the
sincere posting
is done don't be afraid back to the
memes and irony soon also feel free to
reach out to me if you have any
questions about
youtube or college or i mean i don't
know what you're you know what's going
on i reached out to some people like
daniel green you know early on and he
was very kind to me and gave me advice
it feels weird just to be talking to the
camera and say hey this is the video
hopefully this was somewhat
fun thanks for watching alright bye bye